I think more kids should take way more
humble jobs my number one piece of
advice is you're 21 live as humble as
you can not on your parents dollar live
with four roommates but be the admin the
assistant the intern to the intern of
the person that you most want to be like
even if that person disappoints you
because if you can see their actions
you'll be able to watch what you don't
like and what you do like it that they
do but you're going to learn so much
when you're closest to the Sun Chris
Brickley a great NBA basketball shooting
coach if you're right now 19 and you're
like I don't want to be a doctor lawyer
engineer well then DM Chris prickly 25th
times nicely don't be spam bot try
different ways because you gotta ask
more than once if you want to get to the
Sun and ask to be the intern why are so
many of my former admins my partners in
business the president of be friends
former interns my partners in empathy
both interns why because they learn most
by watching me do weird things so if you
want to be Anna Wintour if you want to
be a Maverick Carter if you want to be
whoever you think is the coolest